[Music]
anyway we can get her back in LA so you
can have that grandbaby with me back
really soon Khloe Kardashian is
officially back in LA that's excited
over the weekend the reality star
returned home and it seems she and
boyfriend Tristan Thompson are enjoying
some quality time together
check out the couple on Tuesday hitting
up a McDonald's drive-through glow money
keeping a low profile with dark
sunglasses back in April Tristan made
headlines for allegedly cheating on
Chloe while she was pregnant with their
daughter true but now a source tells ET
Chloe has forgiven him and they're
committed to rebuilding their
relationship quote her family was
obviously very concerned when the
scandal broke and they wanted her to
come home from Cleveland but she decided
to stay and is so happy she did why the
source says it was all about family time
after Tru was born April 12th quote
those are important months as a parent
and she is grateful they experienced
that as a team as for Tristan the source
told us he knows he has no more chances
and has to prove himself the NBA star
will have plenty of chances to do so
this summer in LA what the plan is to
live together as a family at Chloe's
home friends family and Chloe have all
forgiven him and are giving him this
second chance and so far it's been
working for them
[Music]
[Applause]